what is the most garbage way to defrost
chicken
my father-in-law said to throw it in a
jacuzzi and stated yeah that's how you
do it
is he jimmy buffett what the [ __ ]
that's crazy
is that how you ate chicken growing up
out of the jacuzzi chicken
yes
let that chlorine flavor sink
in i don't need no probiotic in this
house we're all cleaned out
a little bit that jacuzzi water
straighten you up
i just picture a family in a hot tub and
then like a couple [ __ ] flies
floating around like
but let me ask you this though
you have a jacuzzi there's got to be a
little bit of cash behind that was it
attached to a pool or was it a stand
alone
it was in the front it was in the front
yard wasn't it bro
it's probably in the living room it was
in the front yard
oh my god
let the neighbors take a peek
looking's for free
i got five chickens in here [ __ ]
two sets of titties let's go
god damn
how was the chicken
you wouldn't eat it what'd you say i
don't feel well you're like i'm not
eating your [ __ ] jacuzzi chicken
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what are we having tonight spaghetti get
in the bathtub
get that meatballs in the sink god damn
it
where did he look like he's never been
watching a cooking show and saw that go
down rachel ray's never like fire up the
jacuzzi we're making montreal chicken
tonight
holy [ __ ] one more time for scottie d
and his wife it was beautiful
phoenix
good lord all right andrew oh yeah
where are you at andrew
what's up brother how you feeling that
woman just went whoa and she's like yeah
it's me and then she's never mind he's
over there
what's up bro how are you who are you
here with brother
all right cool i like it i [ __ ] like
it
coming out and showing up
very nice how'd you get here drive yeah
kind of whip you're rolling around in
86
1986
[Applause]
[Applause]
i'm sure they were thrilled you bought a
brand new car
instead of moving out of their [ __ ]
house
mom it's an 86 what the [ __ ] does that
mean and you're a piece of [ __ ] get
did you out dinner with your parents
tonight with your parents
okay does she leave you something out
when you come home
do you heat it up in the jacuzzi what do
you do
[Applause]
you guys are [ __ ] insane dude
it's knots man look under the hood of
the car i left dinner there for you
there's a couple of baked potatoes in
the tailpipe
holy [ __ ]
what do you do for what do you do for a
ice
living
yeah all right all right so you're
starting your own business
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
you leave your mom's house
go to your mom's
work
come home at your mom's dinner go to
sleep in your bed at your mom's house
it's pretty [ __ ] good dude i can't
hate on that
that's a pretty good [ __ ] gig
you hang onto that [ __ ] as long as you
can man
because he is a pretty classy guy
because his question is it garbage to
have bought drugs with loose change so
you know
things are going great for andrew at the
ice cream shop ask for a raise
[ __ ]
yo man why is there hot fudge all over
these chains
[Laughter]
what kind of drugs were you buying
just weed how much don't tell me like a
quarter pound or something
thrown out with a trunk full of quarters
give me 38 cents a kind bud [ __ ]
i gotta get back to the ice cream shop
don't tell my mom i was here
[Laughter]
how much was it how much change was it
jesus
who's your weed guy the salvation army
what the [ __ ]
that's crazy dude
what drug dealer takes twenty dollars in
change for a gram
you just roll up with a dirty tube sock
like
you want to count it or you trust me
joke's telling you there's only 17.50 in
there
be better if you hadn't like a real nice
briefcase if i could just open it up
like it's a real professional deal
just take it easy man take it easy
you got a coin star here by any chance
dude